is about Halloween might be frightening
proposition for many people but there's
growing online support to change the
date we celebrate Halloween I love this
there's a proposal it's got 67 67
thousand signatures so far to make
Halloween the last Saturday in October I
think this is great because then it's
not on a school night
you can stand as you can see out later
than you normally could it's always a
pain I thought trick-or-treating on a
school night get the kids ready to hit
the road also I always thought it's so
cold in Halloween my next thing would be
could be move it to a warmer is you're
wearing a coat and sometimes you can't
even see the costumes but 51 percent of
Millennials say that Halloween is their
favorite holiday
that surprised me so why cram it into
rushed evening week days when it
deserves a full day they also say the
Halloween costume Association say this
will make Halloween safer for parents
and their kids too I don't wanna make it
safer if you focus it on a Saturday
night then people have all week to get
excited about how crazy they're gonna go
on Saturday night yeah teenagers on a
Saturday night are already difficult in
the fall and there's gonna be Halloween
Saturday night every time we have a
Halloween on that falls on a Saturday we
have some sort of table chat about how
like and you know authorities are
particularly worried about this
Halloween right okay Thank You Debbie
Debbie we can cope with you on the
moving into a warmer part of the
Millennials love Halloween you ever been
on the Lower East Side on Halloween yes
oh man I really that was my dad moment
morning I apologize